[Music]
the official Aladdin remake trailer has
just dropped and similar to the source
material that there's a lot to unpack
from it after the controversial first
look at the Will Smith genie costume we
got a couple of months ago it seems like
the studio have tried to clean him up
this is to appease fans I'm guessing and
now have him in this classic blue hue
but it still looks a little weird
anyway throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the trailer and what we
can take from it there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want to
know anything that I highly suggest that
you turn off now but without the way I'm
definition and welcome to the channel
where I watch it so you don't have to
the trailer opens with a bird gracefully
flying through the Arabian night fans of
the first film will instantly recognize
this as Largo Jafar's parrot he's
probably my favorite character from the
original so it's brilliant to see him
return however we don't get his voice
and those will remember that back in the
day we got Gilbert Gottfried who really
nailed the part I can't find any
information for Largo on IMDB for the
remake so it looks like we won't get the
return of gottfrid which is a big shame
we get some more shot of the mob meeting
that kicked off the original which then
transitions into our first look at you
fall personally I think this looks a bit
like cosplay and I don't really get this
sinister and intimidating vibe of him
that I did with the animated movie
whilst they nailed Aladdin another gripe
I have is with the Cave of Wonders or as
I called it as a kid the tiger temple it
seems to be fully static and whilst they
may animate it later I think that it's
lost a lot of its magic and it leaves
this trailer feeling a bit flat anyway
from here we go to Agrabah and the city
looks fantastic the wedding suit a
parade looks great as does Jasmine she
absolutely nails it and we also get a
glimpse of Raja Raja is fully CGI which
is fine his computers have more than
caught up to how Tigers should look as
we saw in Life of Pi in The Walking Dead
we also see Aladdin meeting jasmine for
the first time and it's clear that's
similar to the original he has used his
wishes to appear rich then the money
shot comes with Aladdin in the Cave of
Wonders as it collapses around him and
then he's forced to rob the lamp the
genie played by
Smith pops out and he's shocked that
Aladdin doesn't know who he is it's
pretty much Will Smith playing Will
Smith and the actor has some pretty big
shoes to fill
Robin Williams obviously left a huge
hole when he passed away and I don't
really feel like Will Smith is nailing
it here like Williams was I love Smith
but it's a bit jarring to see the blue
skin tones and maybe this will work
better after some adjustment but we'll
have to see
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the trailer as well as if there's
anything that I missed make sure you
leave them in the comments below and if
you enjoyed this video then please give
it a thumbs up and make sure you check
out my breakdown of the childsplay
remake trailer which will be linked at
the end this is the channel for people
who were mad into movies so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]